i'm doing a 72 hour fast three days
only water coffee and electrolytes
sodium potassium magnesium
the video is brought to you by cash app
thanks a lot to them
for being a long time supporter of this
channel
also athletic greens for being a long
time supporter of my diet
electrolytes are coming from a few
sources including element
one packet of which has one gram of
sodium 200 milligrams of potassium and
60 milligrams of magnesium
i also have these in uh pill form
one gram of sodium and uh 120 milligrams
of magnesium
that's good especially when i'm doing a
lot of running i'm currently
25 hours into the fast i'm tracking it
with the
xero app they used to be a sponsor of
the podcast i'm not sure if they're
sponsored anymore
anyway i love using them i don't care if
they're spawns or not that's actually
true for all the sponsors
i'm still doing light exercise like i
just did a slow pace run for about
four miles and then i also did about 100
push-ups and about 50 or 60 pull-ups and
i'm hoping to do the same tomorrow and
the day after
why am i doing the fast that's an
important question i think
first and foremost is to reflect on life
i know perhaps you don't need it
but i personally like to create forcing
functions for myself to
pause and reflect on all the things that
i'm grateful for
in this life and really i'm talking
about just simple things the fact that
i'm alive at all
the fact that i have food the fact that
i have shelter the fact that i have
people
who i love and that bring joy to my life
and the fact that i love basically
everything about this life all the
things i get to do
i really enjoy in fact i enjoy basically
anything i do so
that i'm deeply grateful for i'm not
exactly sure why but there's something
about
fasting that forces you to really
appreciate
how short this ride is like the fact
that you need food to
run this thing somehow as a reminder
that this is a
a thing with an expiration date quickly
approaching one
i'm just a hamster briefly stepping out
of the hamster wheel
to reflect on how awesome it is to be in
this one particular cage
we call earth i intermittent fast 16 8
or 24 hours very often
it always makes me feel great so the
second reason i'm doing the fast
is for the health benefits you can look
into the science there's a lot of
writing out there about it but
i tend to prefer to be a scientist of n
of one of myself and
every time i do the 16 8 intermittent or
the one meal a day 24 hour fast
i just feel great the way my mind feels
the way my body feels
so i want to try out what 72 hours feels
like because i heard
great things people throw all kinds of
medical terms around like autophagy
from a robotics perspective i tend to uh
think of it as a
hard drive defrag maybe maybe like a
software update
so for the hardware layer it's uh in the
cells it's like a defrag
and the software layer it's uh like a
software update
let's think of it that way finally the
third reason i'm doing the fast is to uh
reset the body in mind
i've uh relaxed the last couple months
or two a little bit too much brisket a
little bit too much whiskey with some
really kind
beautiful texan people but i have a lot
of really difficult tasks coming up
they've been piling up and i need to get
the stuff done so it's time to get back
to work time to get uh focused again
time to make the best of my days my
hours and minutes i should probably say
that i currently
feel great my mind is focused my body
feels great after the run the run felt
great
everything feels great but this is uh
charted territory i am now going into
uncharted territory 48 hours towards the
72 hour mark so let's see how that uh
goes but so far it's a beautiful thing
let's see how i feel
tomorrow quick check in at the end of uh
day two
49 hours and 57 minutes in
it says uh 69 of the way in 69.
i got a pretty good run in actually
about six miles and i'm now gonna do
about 100 push-ups and 50 pull-ups i'm
feeling pretty good
it's been a crazy busy day i got a
chance to do a four-hour podcast today
i did my usual mumbling and incohesive
conversational skills but not worse than
usual
so it's at the same level and my mind is
actually sharper than ever it's really
able to focus on the main task i have to
do and there's a liberating aspect to
not having to think about food even
though i eat
rarely throughout the day and i eat the
same thing there's still a kind of
anticipation towards uh
what you're gonna eat later in the day
as i mentioned in the podcast actually
it feels like
thinking about food is kind of like when
you talk about the weather
it's like the easy thought to have and
when you don't have a chance to have the
easy thoughts
you can now focus on the more difficult
thoughts like i can anticipate
the exciting thing i'm doing later
tonight i'm actually going to read the
hunger artist again
by kafka as was mentioned in the podcast
i used to love that book and i
used to read it a lot before i even
discovered even intermittent fasting
this many many years ago
i was captivated by the madness and the
artistry
of what the main character was doing i
recommend that
i think it's a short story i remember
correctly the hunger artist
anyway i feel great i gotten a chance to
kind of breathe in
and appreciate the hell out of life
especially the conversation i had today
was
on uh the self-destruction of human
civilization
via the man-made engineering of viruses
so the fasting combined with pondering
all the ways in which human civilization
will destroy itself
made me really appreciate the hell out
of being alive after the past couple of
months
of eating a whole lot of brisket and
drinking
a whole lot of whiskey with a lot of
amazing people
i definitely have some reserves to
basically fast for a very long time so
i'll be okay
i'm feeling really good it's actually
kind of exciting how this particular
biological system is able to
store fat for uh when you actually need
to fast
not this like first world i'm gonna
choose to fast but more like i have to
fast because there's no food
so it's kind of amazing how biology
works like that but i definitely have a
bunch of fat to lose
so i need to harden the body harden the
mind and this is a good reset for that
in the summer i'm doing some difficult
projects in my
work and gonna have some fun with some
difficult projects in the grappling
world and
uh and i do some running with a man mr
david goggins so i can't be
full of uh brisket and whiskey for that
or at least if i am i need to make sure
i'm doing some running and exercise
anyway that's way too much talking for
the day i'm gonna go do some uh
push-ups and pull-ups take a shower and
get back to work
i'll see you tomorrow i'm uh 69 in
i have uh 31 left
and i'm looking forward to uh breaking
the fast tomorrow
responsibly probably with some uh
bone broth and just a little bit of
chicken breast i'm not gonna do the
crazy break the fast with the giant
steak
although i'm very tempted to even the
thought of that
is making me hungry my stomach just
actually woke up it's like wait we're
gonna have
some steak no sometimes it feels like
there's not enough hours in the day
but at the same time when you're running
and there's like a little bit of
hunger and you haven't eaten a long time
and you breathe in it feels like
there's so many seconds in the day it's
just
the day is so long and so full of
amazing experiences
so that duality is so real
when you're fasting that i have so much
[ __ ] to do
i don't know how i'm gonna get it done
and at the same time
every second is full of an eternity
that um that i'm just grateful for so
see you tomorrow
all right here we are at the end of this
fun little journey
day three 75 hours and 44 minutes in
i just weighed myself and i'm 170 on the
dot
actually the first time i stepped on the
scale it said 169.9
and then i couldn't believe it so i
stepped on again and it was 170. that's
why i took the picture
and it was never 169.9 again
i also weighed myself right after eating
three days ago
and i was just a little bit over 180. so
it's about
10 pounds of water weight that i lost
maybe
i would estimate about like one pound of
actual fat
that's not why i did it i did it to
challenge myself i did it to
reset the mind i did to take pause and
reflect on all the things i'm grateful
for maybe if i can
give a few takeaways usually when i do a
16 hour fast or 24 hour fast
one of the biggest benefits is uh the
laser focus
that i'm able to attain and maintain
at rhymes clearly have not lost my sense
of humor
but it hasn't improved at all either so
it's at that low bar of dad jokes
plus a little extra loopy but it is what
it is
i think for day two and day three
there's a bit of an up and down on the
focus but
mostly i've been able to get even an
extra level
of focus that i really enjoyed the
little bit of a downside
there's a bit of a darkness to the way i
saw the world
like i was a little bit sadder i would
say or maybe i was just acknowledging
the
suffering that is life maybe i was more
honest
i'm not sure what kind of experience
people usually have with sleep but
i had excellent sleep i slept over eight
hours
on all the nights it was i woke up
refreshed i was feeling great plus i was
doing the running
so i ran today again four miles
i did push ups and pull ups feeling
great
i was taking the element potassium
magnesium
sodium plus the salt pills i every time
i took that stuff maybe as placebo but
it made me feel really great so a lot of
water i did drink
tea unsweetened obviously just green tea
with mint
and actually two things helped with
hunger
it was a hot tea or really cold water i
don't know how that works i'm sure
there's an explanation for it but
i did feel hungry in unpleasant ways
like
like a hunger ache earlier on in the
process
but i kind of reframed that as an
opportunity to sort of pause and think
and
and then the hunger kind of uh faded
away because when you realize it's not
that
big of a deal i have a lot of fat i'm
gonna be okay
the body's naturally gonna go to the fat
stores i'm talking way too much
i may have mentioned this before but one
of the big things i noticed is
just the experience of being free of
having to think
about what i'm going to eat today even
though i eat the same exact thing
still the experience was that i felt
free to sort of focus and think about
the things i have going on
outside of food like the problems i'm
working on
the things i have on my schedule even
just like small stuff
as i'm saying it now doesn't really make
sense but i really did feel like i
gained a lot of hours in the day by
not having to think about food at all
one of the tougher experiences actually
was
about an hour ago when i went to the
grocery store to get the
chicken breast and the chicken bone
broth which is what i'm going to break
the fast with
i don't know if it was difficult or just
like meditative and beautiful of an
experience
of just walking through especially the
fresh produce part of the store
and just everything looked amazing the
reason i'm breaking the fast with
uh just a little bit of chicken breast
and
a little bit of bone broth is because
i hear bad stories when you just overeat
which is exactly what i want to do right
now
i want to eat a giant steak but i'm
going to be smart about this i'm going
to have a little chicken broth
a uh a little bit of chicken breast and
then just wait three or four hours
and then eat again about a thousand
calories just make a steak
a thousand fifteen hundred calories uh
at night
that's it that'd be it for the day and
then return back to normal diet
normal strict diet tomorrow and then
continuing the running the push-ups and
pull-ups
again harden the body harden the mind
i'm not sure if i fully conveyed this
but it was actually
more challenging than i expected but
it's
not so hard that i can't do it regularly
i like the
george pierre model of doing it like
four times a year especially after you
fall off the wagon of
uh dieting i think i'll do that maybe
i'll try
like five seven day fast at some point
okay
way too much talking time to go eat i've
been looking forward to this all day
maybe i'll get the first couple bites on
camera let's see
how good this chicken and bone broth
taste
all right here we go no reason to wait
we're at uh 76 hours and
24 minutes and i have looked forward to
this
very plain but very incredibly delicious
looking chicken
for quite a few hours now so here we go
this is some good chicken
i taste the caramelized part but most of
all
i taste the coconut oil actually
and the salt the oil and the salt
i think that's what my body was craving
the most
given my keto diet i think the fat is
what i was craving
even though i have plenty of fat the
body still i want more
again it's the salt this tastes
delicious i can't
it'll be hard to just eat this but
that's all i'm doing for the next
let's say four hours about it's just the
bone broth and the chicken this is a
this is a really memorable moment
oh man life is made up of moments like
this
it doesn't take much
this is the best tasting
chicken breast i've ever had in my life
just chicken breast
some spices salt
and 76 hours of fasting
this is incredible damn
damn it's good to be alive
you